no matter what you're on ida things
queer people weren't invented in the
1980s they've literally always existed
hello and welcome to an episode of
historical icons who weren't actually
straight today we'll be talking about
the amazing chevalier dion a french spy
diplomat soldier and person of trans
experience up first some fast facts
in 1728 the chavaya dion was born
charles genevieve louis agust
and somehow having the longest name in
human history isn't what she's famous
for
she was a wiz kid at school and by the
time dion turned 35 she obtained a law
degree published books became a renowned
fencer got knighted and probably made
everyone around her feel like a huge
underachiever
dion had a public career as a diplomat
to russia and england but secretly she
also worked for the most covert spy
service in france known as liv secure or
the king's secret during this time she
successfully infiltrated the court of
empress elizabeth of russia by
presenting as a woman though she
wouldn't transition until many years
later at 32 as a french ambassador and
as a military captain dion fought in the
seven years war and was present to
mediate the peace of paris treaty that
ended it
she helped end a dang war granted the
war did not go well for france but for
her contributions dion was awarded one
of france's highest honors by king louis
xv the order of son louise this is when
she officially took the title of
chevalier which means
knight so she and the king seemed like
they were on good terms but a year later
in 1764 the king booted her out of her
diplomatic liaison job to get back at
him and throw some shade she published a
satirical and popular book of state
secrets that she had collected as a spy
yeah we get it dionne you're good at
everything
and she was also very clever she held
back some of the most damaging secrets
of the crown so even though the book
caused her to be exiled from france she
was able to blackmail the king who kept
her on his payroll until his death in
1774. pretty smart but like many good
stories this one has a tragic ending
dion was jailed for debt in 1804
despite an advance from a publisher to
write a final memoir the chavay dion
spent her last year's bedridden in
poverty until her death in 1810
aged 81.
now on to the cuista
dion presented publicly as a man until
she was 49. after which she presented as
a woman
she had already made an impressive mark
on society before transitioning in 1777
but dion's identity as a woman brought
her even greater fame and celebrity
status
in england she mingled with the rich and
the famous and performed popular
demonstrations as a mass defenser often
while wearing a striking black gown
blinged out with her military medals so
high fashion
perhaps not surprisingly her transition
inspired an ongoing widespread bet about
her gender so people being weirdly and
rudely obsessed with other people's
identities has an unfortunately long
standing history
according to some historians the ark
would challenge anyone who would bet on
her gender identity to a duel
we should definitely keep the tradition
alive
in 1770 a rumor started that dionne had
actually been designed female at birth
but she had been brought up as a man in
order to receive a family inheritance
although after her death a surgeon
claimed dion's biological sex was male
but indian's unpublished autobiography
she herself claimed to have been born
female but was instead raised as a man
by as she put it a father desperate for
her son
so how did dion transition during a time
when it seemed like people were executed
for just thinking queer thoughts well at
the time there were women who just like
mulan dressed up like men to join the
army so dion being a military man who
later revealed herself to be a woman was
not as unusual as you might think and
her transition was generally accepted
besides now being a famous spencer dion
was also held in high regard by
innovative feminists of the time
as a specimen of shining female
fortitude to which english women might
look up to one of these feminist
philosophers was mary wilson craft a
fascinating woman in her own right who
was actually mary shelley's mother yes
that mary shelley you know the 20 year
old author of frankenstein
in conclusion
[Music]
both during her life and for centuries
after the brilliant and the daring
chevalier dion has sparked conversation
and controversy
to some she was a trickster and even a
monster to others a fascinating
celebrity full of talent and intrigue
we still see her influence across all
kinds of popular culture today
in the anime series le chavoie
as the subject of a doctor who audio
drama and even as a character you can
duel in assassin's creed unity
dion is a hero of the lgbtq plus
community because she lived as her
authentic self over 200 years ago during
a time period in which trans people were
not understood
also because she fenced in a dress and
looked awesome doing it take that on ida
make sure to check out the next episode
of historical icons who weren't actually
straight right here